be the longest one Darksiders Zelda and
I'm gonna finish up by noon be nice to
happen just so we don't open the door I
mean if that's your more your call
my stools are pretty fancy oh my god
it's all the glitter I eat damn you guys
are gonna I'm gonna just so we don't get
stuff about not okay everybody what is
brain Peter right Frank
so imagine like general or captain or
private first class just it doesn't
happy military just like any position
any anything that denotes that like yeah
you fit reviews editor yeah
what is the first line of this this is
planet yeah earth yes I think on earth
you can run look at this I don't want
sorry that's this is why do you want to
hand these things are as I said yeah
yeah oh really
right sorry you're totally right damn it
Peter we are gonna who's going first
yeah we could well we can pass those out
okay but actually there should be
mongers um the only thing I would say is
that die hard and Titanic should come
although Sandlot first okay I'll go
first the Goonies after I'm practicing
it then Peter
I like your system 1p it's like one
inside of a circle and then we're like
an alley and then Rob everybody on
YouTube just got the loogie noise as
soon as I signed in why is it why are we
like this
hmm I'm gonna read off the rules too yes
they're important I meant to I thought I
had underlined more important things for
each point you this yeah but we're not
we don't have these events anymore right
you can use them if you don't know we
can use them if you want to it's just
we're not limited to just those for that
section
I'm easily friends
dude bucket cam for right now it just
can you see the feed okay so you know
what I'm talking about
wait do we want people seeing cam for
right now cuz they are oh yeah whatever
can we hide cam for all I can do that
rule 24 a is processed very Seuss hey
that's what you said yes all right sweet
oh it says 24 that's what you did Auto
numbers says 18 I must oh yeah you
probably had the first one so it says
one three oh yeah I'm the best
buses Boston
oh no that was a sorry coffee spilled it
was spilled coffee and then I threw it
at Pete and I forgot and he didn't
notice
so that would there was no like
you'd be surprised can you go higher
left Oh chat knows something's up
are you this suck the Iowa welcome I'm
sure
riot love it's common know what's
happening goob screenshot that I'd still
don't think it would make sense opening
it's also funny to think that
things like
can translate have you have you heard
that supercut him saying liquid it's
just like a liquid great Rick yeah
gamespot office used to be like a mother
soundboard between like Merrill in like
all the yeah we tried doing that with
Ben Janka no see that it
he loves metal Gary yes he has the why
are we talking about metal gear what's
your favorite metal gear I don't even
say like Mel Gear Solid Snake it's it's
five or it's all your stuff yeah good
mind still three I think but that was
mine for a while
but now when I go back to play it the
beginning is bad won't fight against
like Ocelot and those dudes I don't like
that part we add Japanese maybe getting
a free mmm-hmm
beginning ish Oh like after the boss
after you meet the boss on the bridge
well depending on how this goes
yeah when you come back and say goodbye
something else we over and raise my
chair know something that otacon's is
Otacon has this whole thing about his
Japanese animes who's never worked
Oh Dickon can can you can cocaine hmm
I kind of wish damn it I can't say good
Hank him okay
[Music]
Darksiders dark sliders today Oh
you know what today's May 3rd Rob not
the 4th
you
shirt looks like John Luke is handling a
piece of c4 very little reaction from
him on that front
cuz he's like [ __ ] we found out
Gianluca might be a demolitions expert
in another another field
[Music]
vas up everyone welcome back to the
lobby GameSpot's weekly hangout I'm your
host Mike McCarty here as usual with
Pete Brown hello
Callie plaguey hello and Robert handler
II it's good to be alive did that with
his Star Wars shirt a day earlier you
have another one that you're gonna wear
tomorrow for may the fourth yeah you
know I do I hate that I hate that day
because it just sounds like everyone has
a lisp that's rude I just I hate having
that th down in there um anyway we have
kind of a weird show today
I'll admit that up front which you tuned
in early enough to see something we got
set up in the studio we got a bit of a
weird segment but we'll get to that
later first off as usual we have a
giveaway thanks to Shiva our Twitter
manager it is ps4 Keys for Marvel heroes
Omega beta unfortunately this is only
for ps4 in North America but if you
don't follow GameSpot on Twitter go
follow us and then retweet the giveaway
tweet that Shiva will send out and if
you're in the twitch chat she'll usually
put that in here if you're on YouTube
like I said just go to Twitter and later
in the week we'll pick winners to send
those out too we have a bunch I think we
started off with no joke 80,000 of them
so depending on how many people watch
the stream today we might run out but it
remains to be seen um yeah and if you're
on YouTube or twitch or GameSpot we have
a chat up here so we're always welcoming
questions I got some questions about
Darksiders 3 about the parade mo about
Zelda DLC via Twitter this morning so we
always welcome the audience
participating uh and one news item I
want to get out remedy entertainment who
did a quantum break they there's new
details about their new games gonna be
published by 505 games
it's codenamed p7 and believe it or not
get this this is huge it's gonna be a
cinematic third-person action experience
no [ __ ] yeah Pete you uh you didn't
really you got some flack for quantum
break right yeah did you give us 7 6 Wow
it wasn't a good game yeah I never
played it oh I'd like live stream back
with like Danny O'Dwyer in the day I
liked there were moments in combat which
were good which I wasn't surprised
because it's like yeah like remedy has
always made games where I like that sort
of aspect to it but it was the
it was just the real convoluted
everything else in the game yeah sort of
maze we've seen what they do with this
if you want more details on it the news
stories on GameSpot they have like
numbers and figures and royalty rates
and stuff like that it was a pretty
detailed report but go check that out
anyway okay let's get into it
last week the prey first our demo went
up on a ps4 Xbox one PC I leave all
three platforms
no no not pc ok ps4 Xbox one it's a
point of controversy for a lot of people
actually right maybe that's why didn't
that was there any discussion why they
didn't do that no but the I forget the
developers name arcane no like the
individual individual develop yes i
person a developer someone was asking
about you know what is there a pc port
and the guy said no because we're
developing the game natively on pc well
no [ __ ] you're not developing the game
like using a PlayStation 4 but the
Dishonored 2 PC release had a lot of
problems right so we release the demos
that didn't release a demo for PC and
now everyone is kind of like well what
are we to believe right you're saying
okay um it's weird yeah I wonder if
they're just like really playing it safe
or something as far as like they're
launched oh yeah you could get it out
there so people could test it and
actually report like yeah my rig doesn't
work on this oh we didn't test that rig
we didn't know that those variables
might be an issue I mean if anything
this would behoove them to do this now
so they don't have customers upset when
they get the thing that they've paid 60
bucks for was that Raph Cole Antonio by
chance signed that on Twitter you love
to say his name
great name it is a great name uh no I
don't think it was him it might have
been though okay um but the first hour
demo was on for ps4 Xbox one last week a
few of us got the chance to play it Rob
you played this a couple times now
between the demo and like doing this as
a preview event back in the day sure
yeah and people around the office are
excited including myself just because
you know it's I liked arcane stuff I
love Dishonored 2
I love that you know like everybody call
it a spiritual successor to Bioshock
System Shock I'm really excited for that
kind of game those immersive Sims so I'm
excited for this but I kind of want to
get people to take that I've tried it
out around the office Rob I think you
have the most experience with it what's
your are you excited based on bud I am
I'm excited to see what
err that game gets to because you know
they definitely create something where
there is a replayability factor like it
there's experimentation like you see
these videos to more was was you know
you can morph as the game progresses you
can morph into like any kind of object
like the aliens you see the mimics that
crawl so I think tomorrow was messing
around with like just a toilet paper
watching themself and rolling around
sound listen and just yeah it doesn't
know you can disguise yourself you can
then cheat the system and I think Aaron
was telling me it's been really
interesting where they in the demo they
actually lock it off as far as like when
you get that first open area room or
their series of different ways where you
can kind of you know choose your own
path apparently people like found a kind
it's like a crossbow nerf gun that to my
understanding just shoots darts however
there is an area where you're not
supposed to get through yet the purpose
of this gun is actually to shoot darts
through cracks and hit the switch from
the inside of the room and open it up
and so people were actually able to kind
of already kind of like not exploit but
like experiment again like and like
found a way to like actually get a
little further than anyone else so I
just I'm really interested to see the
late game but from the beginning our is
so far has been really good I think I
was seeing that today actually like the
I'm sure people have seen it like the
first hour actually has a 15 minutes of
the demo is like had a big spoiler as
far as a twist in the story and I
spoiler if it's 15 minutes in if we
don't know it already it's just one of
those cases where it's I mean I do it
just boil herbivore they play absolutely
because you want that to happen you know
natural yeah um they've had a tough job
marketing this because yes a some people
think it's you know a lot of people
fighters prey to rather than a reboot
that arcane took over because dishonor
was more of a thief kind of style game
spiritual successor and this they've
been marking as Bioshock System Shock
they but they also don't want to show
people too much about this game but then
when they do it's kind of you know like
lose-lose situation but I do agree that
I wish maybe they had prepped a demo
that started after that kind of thing
started but it
tough spoiler right but don't to talk
about it but it if you've watched
coverage at all on this game you know
where things go eventually but it would
be cool to experience the kind of I
don't know portal to vibes you get right
the beginning for the first time sure
yeah it's just it's hard to say anything
just because in this demo you're just
not to my understanding you're not given
what this game actually like gets to or
amounts to where you're taking alien
parts and making ammo out of it you just
barely it feels like you barely get to
where the meat of this game is but it's
still a pretty cool experience like I
actually miss huge fan of these mimics
here that you're killing like just
walking into a room and feeling so
uneasy because they because three of
them have formed a of a spot radio setup
and you just don't know and next you
know you there's a lot of jump scares in
you and I feel like you are uneasy just
because of you know the fact that
anything in the room can be one of these
guys to jump out at you
you know you see the glue gun here we
saw the wrench I was in the shotgun the
shotgun looks very much like the
Bioshock shotgun you mentioned that
crossbow
so I glue cannon not glue gun but I have
a question from gamespot a rigid goop
shoe riot he says well skills be open to
unlock from start will there be a
progression system uh yeah like this
thing - I need 'l the io your neuro mods
oh yeah shoving a needle in your eye
every time you want to upgrade which is
sick to like compare it to something
else it's like a tonics from bioshock
infinite plasmids from Bioshock on right
I'm pretty sure as far as what I've seen
is you have like three general abilities
like things like hacking and security
that are more they're more specific to
the environment and how you can get
farther as far as opening doors and etc
but then the other thing there's three
or maybe more of just the alien powers
that you eventually like research or
scan wherever you want to call it and
then you become
or to you absorb their power so the
mimicking right you absorb the the mimic
power to all around it's a coffee mode
do whatever you want yeah in order to
you know get through that little slit on
like a bank teller window or there they
go rygaard all there so they're really
they're kinda cute I think they're kind
of you to like if you let me see one
sometimes I'll like wave it you and then
he'll just like run away kill you yeah
okay flipping you the bird though and
you just don't know because they have a
wisp of smoke for an arm not actual
fingers sure Pete Callie what about what
about you - are you guys excited from
what you've seen at the demo or just
what you've seen from what little pre
coverage they've had I still am waiting
to play when the game is actually
released we didn't really want to get
started and then have to stop as you're
safe yeah doesn't say I thought it was
going to at first but then everyone told
me no so it was a transfer right right
yeah exactly and that's the other part
for me too is that even if the the save
was you you were able to transfer your
ps4 save over to the final game I still
wouldn't play it because I wanna play on
a PC mm I heard there were some problems
with the controls as far as like a kind
of clunkiness or whatever you want to
call it which apparently I think they
spoke out and said that they are aware
of and will address it but regardless
like just like Dishonored I really want
to play this with a mouse keyboard it's
great especially with these frantic
moments with like a wrench which also
isn't like always at the ready as a
melee you know just like I feel like
Bioshock right we had to switch to that
weapon so you're not I don't know you
want to have that like really quick
ability to defend yourself I'm just to
get back to the idea of like am i
looking forward to this like I when I
watch this footage I really don't know
what is interesting about this it's
really really tough but everyone who's
played the game has said so many great
things about it that I'm almost just
more curious than am excited yeah yeah I
think the it's a difficult thing to
watch being played because a lot of it
is the atmosphere like I think it's it
has this like spooky like there's a lot
of tension right like you don't know if
you're going into a room if the mimics
are disguising themselves to something
um I think that's more interesting to me
than just watching it played like I'm
even watching this now I'm kind of like
this is not what I would be doing oh
yeah I am weird gameplay and it's that
part like it's just not the kind of game
I would want to watch like I wouldn't
want to watch somebody else play
Dishonored either that might be just me
but I think more of it is about the
atmosphere and I'm definitely intrigued
by that like that's the kind of thing I
do really enjoy interesting interesting
you said dishonor because when I think
of dishonored the series in general like
you want to see people maybe streamers
who are extremely good right we're doing
like irises highlights or speedruns this
is a game I feel like could have that
ability because I think you've seen or
heard like you have you get I think you
get a Billy Slater honor it's like
kinetic blast and the mimicking ability
so people or they're allowing you to
shape-shift into a mug and then launch
yourself up onto a Ledge two floors up
in order to like get that jump so I
think they're possibly catering to that
but again like that's just like so later
on like I haven't really seen enough of
that and this is just this hour just
yeah seems just too white to play
devil's advocate I like that they
haven't shown much and I mean I think in
a world where movies the movie trailers
show off everything and it's different
with games but but I does but usually
there's like a promise with a movie
trailer right like unum doesn't show
everything like you kind of like I don't
really know what I'm gonna get out of
this game other than I can turn myself
into things and once in a while I'll
find something that's an alien yeah oh
and I guess I'm in an experiment like
yeah yeah God like I like the tone of
all of that I guess that's what I was
getting getting at is like this demo
establishes tone more than anything else
to me sure that's the part that gets me
interested in it structurally oh god oh
my god this freaks me out
structurally as the game is more of one
big mission rather than these discrete
ones in Dishonored I'm curious to see
how that will play out because I'm sure
like we'll be doing things in different
order and whatnot the people playing it
but yeah I'm excited to see highlight
reels and whatnot I'll would see how it
actually shapes up once it releases it
does it seems like
the kind of game that I want to play at
my own pace and I'm hoping it
facilitates that but I guess it remains
to be seen this game releases Friday and
because the pathetic game because of
that policy they we don't even have code
yet so we might have them pretty much at
release but our review will be up won't
be up right at release tomorrow in the
UK is going to be working on that
Linden let me speak to this a little bit
more yeah so we'll be getting code
tomorrow as well anyone who can access
like the Australian Network accounts
because there are 17 hours ahead of us
in the future so we will have a review
in progress ready before the weekend so
you won't have to wait too long if
you're on the fence to hear some opinion
but it will be based on you know the
first half dozen hours of the game
something like that I think Co Pape said
the game is 16 to 20 hours long tomorrow
I was thinking like 40 oh I thought I'd
Cheryl selects you eight pretty greatly
maybe if you really rush it I'm just
honored to I think me like 18 I think a
lot of people finished in like 13 okay
but that depends on your play style
right on and I don't I'm assuming I
mentioned this but for those wondering
like it's Arkane Studios who also did
Dishonored that's why we're drawing all
this comparisons um yeah this releases
on ps4 Xbox one and PC Friday so we will
like pizza and have a review and
progress up as soon as possible for more
thoughts on that from tomorrow in the UK
and I'm looking forward to it I know
we're all curious so I'm looking forward
to seeing what happens ah cool so that's
prey there was one more part that goob
had in his question he wanted if you
have been watching the lobby for a while
when we were talking about watchdogs
to once I said it was like bedazzled and
people laughed until we rolled the
footage and realize it's actually pretty
similar but he asked me how prey
compares to bedazzled and he and the
chat wanted me to say that out loud but
I didn't think was relevant but when his
bedazzled not relevant but as well it is
always applicable you should go watch
that if you have never seen it I watch
it every day before I come to work it's
a gem Elizabeth Hurley is great in it
Brendan Fraser's just weird as ever it's
no friends but all right cool anyway
alright cool
all right so uh joey is joining us in
the studio here if we could switch over
he's got some sick outfit on well uh
you'll notice he's standing next to a
whiteboard and most of them most of you
will probably see that those are Hideo
Kojima kind of Metal Gear Solid all
Metal Gear it's all Metal Gear
characters organizations and activities
Joey edit naked cartwheels which I write
in fans out there yeah and I know this
is confusing and we're still kind of
confused I'm kidding we are going to so
last week tribeca Games Festival in New
York City took place and Hideo Kojima
was there to talk about kind of death
stranding and movie influences and just
inspiration in general and they asked if
he were to make a movie what it would be
and people asked us on time because of
your solid Hideo Kojima's games in
general are always super his body is 70%
movies cinematic yeah ah between escape
from New York Titanic um die hard
they're all kind of big influences but
did you see though during that steam
interview I don't know if you read it
escape from New York Snake Plissken is
not the influence that went into Metal
Gear Solid it was actually Robert De
Niro from Deerhunter uh-huh what yeah
interesting my whole life is a lie
[ __ ] regardless some point he
answered if I were to start making a
movie I might not finish it because he
loves movies so much but he also said he
would be up for a big-budget blockbuster
which I think we would all expect or a
smaller feature with a few characters in
a single room a lot diehard um single
building single room you get me so Pete
Brown brought the idea to us you know
what if what if a Okajima did direct not
just a movie in the future but some of
our favorite movies from the past yeah
and I'm gonna let Pete kind of describe
the rules of this more open-ended
segment and Joe is gonna help us out and
we're gonna do some some weird stuff
alright so because we're basing this on
pre-existing movies we can't just start
from scratch right so what I've done is
I've created sort of a Madlib scenario
where we can use the terms that Joey has
up there plus you know verbs adjectives
that we just think up to rewrite the
synopsis that was originally found on
the back of the movie box the VHS knob
the VHS or the DVD
sure sure um and the rules are each new
suggestion comes from the next host at
the podium so we're going to go down the
line one by one so we're not just
shouting over each other key movie
characters have to be replaced with key
Metal Gear characters that's because we
it'll make sense in a second it does
host may veto one suggestion per slot
barring it's for the bet the good of the
film and Hideo Kojima the synopsis must
retain the spirit of the original film
and also must acquire the spirit of
Hideo Kojima lastly there's one more
rule everyone please take this very
seriously
also last rule you didn't add it have
fun have fun take it seriously
I believe I'm gonna kick this off right
and so we are going to roll a trailer
after we fill this in and mike is going
to read the synopsis over it and rob is
sort of cut trailers for these okay cool
more or less so all right repeat I need
a character um fat man okay
all right Rob I need an organization
wait who well bones like just add fat
man across I'm in across it out so
rollerblading demolitions expert
organization uh Foxhound
okay uh Callie I need an adjective any
adjectives get weird with it no don't
get me um explosive nice oh that's
really good
verb Pete um smell okay
Robin yeah location Bermuda Callie
another adjective big
Pete I need an activity oh yeah here um
go with cloning hell yeah you guys have
taken all the good ones uh Rob another
activity separate one I've already
started Reno's uh I'm not gonna take
flirting no I'm not gonna do it someone
else to do that uh developing MOOCs you
know the other good one I have I said
what movie this is yet should I wait
okay should we all right uh Callie
adjectives again um
naked nice no that's not no it is this
is uh to say okay another character Pete
another character I'm gonna go with
Meryl nice Meryl
this is alright another character Rob
Vulcan Raven hahaha alright uh did I get
a location yet no I did not
cal any location wait I thought I'd rob
you Rob gave me berries at the same
location I can't look it is if it says
location one you're totally right I'm
sorry
um okay Callie I need a plural noun
bombs okay
Oh story in life I need a relationship
Pete oh boy uh kissing cousins okay
horrible bad [ __ ] like uh robbed another
or nothing
never mind Juan let me fill out this I
got organization one again okay Rob
adjective uh smelly Cali one more
adjectives and then this is the last one
get nuts with it um exotic ok so try
tell the movie yet are we gonna roll the
trailer and all over the trailer that's
right and you go ahead and read it you
can write time these are about a minute
thirty long ok less than that so
consider the clock down there if you
need to all right John Luke hit me with
it I don't know which movie it is oh um
it's it's the one that starts with s
what about the starts with an S there's
a lot of boys in it I can do that ok
thank you sorry my bad are you gonna
unmute the TV no we're good right
alright here we go it's the early 1960s
and fat man has just moved into town
with his Fox hound kids callin explosive
he can't even throw a baseball but that
changes when the leader of Foxhound
invites him to smell on the nearby
Bermuda field at the beginning of a big
summer of cloning wild developing nukes
first kisses a naked confrontation with
the dreaded Merrill and his owner Vulcan
Raven who lived behind Bermuda soon 9
bombs have become best kissing cousins
fat man is a part of Fox sound and their
leader has become a local legend in this
smelly and exotic comedy
and that's the synopsis right there
let's keep rolling this oh yeah we
probably should have slowed this down uh
[Laughter]
mommy skip ad' now you're good again
there's the kissing cousins who didn't
come yeah wow that was an actual edit
the same lot there we go hello there we
go alright as that was what it would be
like if Jo Kojima directed Sam lot one
of my favorite movies of all time all
right
Pete's your turn this one's got a lot of
adjectives Mike give me an adjective
phrase bombastic okay Rob I need an
adjective sweaty all right I need
another education Kellie short short
uh actually I'm gonna view to that one
okay
mm very tight I see one more adjectives
I'm not joking um superfluous okay I
need a plural noun uh go-carts sorry
everyone uh uh I need an adjective
Oh for me um
terrible terrible uh I'm gonna pass on
that one sorry guys I just want this to
be perfect like I said a Nakajima would
do it okay um effervescent okay sure
uh all right I need a noun uh
grandmother right I need a number
Oh God
ten okay I need an adjective
oh damn it um
romantic your feet okay okay no no no no
no no it's good it's good
I need another adjective please mmm
leathery Wow
actually yeah that works damn looking at
Richard's boots iOS body part
arm okay all right
character so as a meddler character it's
the first making a feeling for doesn't
mean use as much as it should be
revolver ocelot cool all right I need a
noun Michael feces oh sorry I shouldn't
now Robert
I'd desk sure you look good done
adjectives I know you've got a couple
more to go um blind all right I need a
plural noun and then we're good lizards
all right
roll that beautiful footage of the start
of the G start to the G thank you
from the imagination of Hideo Kojima The
Goonies plunges a band of bombastic
heroes into a sweaty surprise around
every corner quest beyond their wildest
dreams
following a hairy treasure map into a
spectacular underground rep realm of
twisting passages superfluous booby
go-karts and a long effervescent pirate
ship full of golden grandmothers begin
the kids race to stay ten steps ahead of
a family of bumbling romantic guys and a
leathery monster with an arm only a
revolver ocelot could love I love it
alright I'm gonna give it a second I
give it a second okay Oh a feces
adventure classic from start to
buccaneering finish
The Goonies is a cinematic desk trove of
blind action dazzling lizards and
shivery Timbers thrills
alright that was not good
I was just a weird orb of the weird one
that was weird
alright I think we could probably go the
next right yeah I'm sorry
alright move it or not now we're going
to Kali but I'll just joining we are
getting to zelda breath of the wild DLC
and Darksiders three stuff this is just
if hideo kojima made our favorite movies
because of that quote from the tribeca
games festivals for idiots yeah I need a
location
um alright I'm going to say South Africa
that's all I oughta pay ssin like uh
plumber okay a character uh big boss
okay
um a different location here um Oakland
okay uh adjectives uh did we use
effervescent why is that in my head we
did okay that's why uh uh flamboyant
okay I know it's all that okay I
remember one movie a sir oh yeah I do
one event the apocalypse oh you better
be able to read this um chats been
spitting these out um dance
I'm gonna veto that okay um strangle
yeah hunter and uh organization uh PETA
Oh from there mmm [ __ ] I like PETA
better alright diamond dogs
it's kind of like PETA
uh noun submarine okay does it work
yes okay oh this is the same diamond
dogs okay
character - I need a second character
I'm going to say Coldman
adjectives plural I mean it's for a
plural noun
it's just logic - okay um
foamy no no you oceanic that works with
the summer you know here we go
known um swordfish
okay I think we've lost sight of what
the real goal is here um definitely
crying um soldier no I love your ex yeah
I Metal Gear Rex Thank You suggestion Oh
to get us back to Cody yeah good point
yeah you're right um noun
um Metal Gear RAY no note um I don't
know
nano bots okay I like then a machine in
a machine a machine oh this is character
one big boss
uh no katana too slippery oh okay thank
you and adjectives gaseous okay um John
Luke rolled d movie yeah Bruce Willis
stars as South Africa plumber big boss
newly arrived in okay to spend the
Christmas holiday with his flamboyant
wife
but uh but as Big Boss waits for his
wife's office a pilot stainable Diamond
Dogs seize control of the submarine
while the Diamond Dogs leader Coleman
and his oceanic henchmen round up
swordfish yeah big boss slips away
unnoticed armed with only a Metal Gear
Rex at his nanomachine big boss launches
his own one-man katana a slippery seller
from beginning to end
diehard explodes with gaseous cash is
one guess Bentley and a hard man to kill
die die hard
you trip the narrator up with your edit
what yeah yeah oh man that's my life all
right let's do this last one kind of
quick yeah a long one and let's then
we'll get to Darksiders and zelda and
its really try to stick to middle gear
okay we can do it you want still do it
move on mm mm I kind of want to do it
let's do it okay we committed to it
let's do it planet Saturn adjective
uh roundabout
another adjective bizarre are you crying
Kelly number 400 Academy Award uh pass
yes Best Original Screenplay adjective
deadly genre comedy plural noun
um rollerblading demolition experts are
bde for sure um um I'm fresh it feet
okay just cuz you don't yeah that's it
oh yeah how about uh florid sure nice
time frame um so I will say uh week rank
mmm private first class another rank a
different one from me yeah um CEO
instead of rank sure we have not hit
melech here yeah uh character one there
we go oh here we go thank various here's
Joey character one za me yeah liquid
snake
character to riding me look how much
this you kept his job
Jesus plural noun oh no no as you guys
sorry um bullets hmm controversy
controversy huh
okay let me see if I can uh no it's me
Shadow Moses incident oh it's okay now
once I shut Shadow Moses Institute sorry
you can take next on cons your first
weirdest category of word verb uh uh
fulton conspire do torture let's go
tortured yeah
sorry babe yeah adjective flirty proper
noun
how's Emmy yeah fine um the USS
Enterprise
adjective uh smoky no no sorry
disastrous wait until a long one
noun word robe malfunction nice
adjective a mickey cross a cross that
plural noun
philosophers I use one of the
organization adjective aromatic is good
a room Eric green aromatic aromatic nice
one Eric really thank you for your dream
has guy given me two so far number uh
ninety one adjectives
horrific we're all going to lose our
jobs after this adjective that's it last
one um good late
you doubt getting one more okay um I
gotta Joey oh it's only you do murderous
murderous all right here we go last
woman thank you for singing with us bear
with me on this one if hideo kojima
directed this movie this is what it
would be spin it nothing on Saturn can
rival roundabouts spectacle and bizarre
grandeur of Titanic winner of 400
Academy Awards including Best Original
Screenplay this deadly comedy story
sailed into the hearts of rollerblading
demo experts around the globe ultimately
emerging as the most flawed motion
picture of the week International
International private first class
private first class Leonardo DiCaprio
line up excuse wind-up sorry light up
the screen as liquid snake and ridin the
young bullets separated by Shadow Moses
incident right yeah The Shadow Moses
incident yet dis destined to torture
each other on the mate hahahaha named
voyage of the flirty RMS USS Enterprise
but when the but when did sorry uh but
when the disasters sorry Jesus
but when the doom disasters liner what
[ __ ] but when the doom disasters liner
collides with a wardrobe malfunction and
the sneaky North Atlantic their their
philosophers love affair becomes an
aromatic race to a for survival from
acclaimed filmmaker and ninety-one Oscar
winner if they Okajima comes a tale of
horrific love in the face of disaster
that triumph as a murderous cinematic
masterpiece alright would we got through
it alright for those joining those were
some of our favorite movies as directed
by Hideo Kojima happy but also not but
also just kind of mad lit that's some
classic 90s uh alright let's talk about
videogames so
let me come back down to earth for a
second Joe he's done no none he's
unboxing that [ __ ] right now Joey thank
you on those our live production man
who's naked cartwheels remains uh okay
IGN THQ Nordic and vigil games announced
Darksiders 3 IG n first add more details
on it and I'm pretty excited about this
Darksiders 1 & 2 I really liked
Darksiders vigil games emerge kind of
doing a Zelda clone for lack of a better
term deal with war one of the four
horsemen and then Darksiders 2 came out
and you were death going through an
open-world kind of puzzle environmental
puzzle platforming heavy kind of hack
and slash adventure and now dark times 3
you are fury the sister to the four
horsemen and we kind of want to talk
about what we wanted our exciters 3 I
think I'm probably the biggest
Darksiders fan in the office so I guess
I'll start but just to preface it so
Fury is going to be more of a whip based
character so people on Twitter we're
asking on a second mm she's the sister
of the four horsemen is she not a horse
woman I don't know I asked him the real
man would imagine uh but we did have a
question uh poison ivy the audios on
John Luke is rolling this with the audio
we could watch this if we want we could
but keep going
uh yeah so Fury's gonna be almost like a
bayonetta thing kind of like whips and
more you know like fluid kind of combat
and almost like God of War even with
Kratos and his blades of chaos but here
you see the elder charred council if I
recall correctly but here's fury herself
and you see war kind of chained up right
here from the first game but yeah she'll
be she's more mage based based on the
news she will be kind of transforming
into different forms making use of those
maybe elemental powers you can see her
here in terms of what we want this
trailer doesn't show much so John Luke
you could probably actually like cut it
here in terms of what we want I want to
see them actually kind of expand it cuz
Darksiders one was pretty small and
confined compared to Darksiders to
Darksiders to they actually give you
this open world to travel through they
there were many more like incidental
side bosses here you see her talking to
the Smith from Darksiders to I think
that's him it looks like a very exciting
conversation abhi yeah they're pretty
into it so here we are yeah and we will
essentially be it'll be more of an open
world of course but it's also cool that
it's David Adams who worked on the
original game at Joe Madureira David
Adams actually recently worked on
Chronos really good VR game P you liked
it I liked Chronos a helluva lot so yeah
I heard good things about that so they
know what they're doing in terms of 3d
action-adventure kind of stuff Chronos
was a pretty good example that but same
with Darksiders wanted to so it's kind
of people Darksiders to who had a bunch
of new people on it but uh then the THQ
dissolution happened and Darksiders kind
of fell off the face of the earth for a
while but they were almost like cult
classics and people kept asking for a
sequel and now there's gonna be THQ
Nordics first game and gunfire games
will be working on this but they are
kind of focused more on like an
open-world that says she's tracking down
the seven deadly sins as the bosses that
was kind of a thing the bosses in
Darkseid were one and two were like you
know like more typical Zelda kind of
scale bosses so I'm curious to see I
would like to see them kind of form the
world around those seven deadly sins so
maybe you go into there
fighting lust and it's a lot different
than gluttony and whatnot if you see
near that movie se7en know if you've
seen seven with Brad Pitt and Morgan
Freeman then maybe you know what to
expect but uh yeah people keep making
comparisons to what's the character's
name from Bayonetta no huh that's not
Bayonetta um I know this is not it's not
coming to me I don't have it no okay but
anyway people are making comparisons to
kind of platinum style action just
because she has a whip but I mean I
thought the action when two was good it
was more scythe based I would like to
see them actually kind of figure out new
ways to incorporate her powers into the
trevore into like environmental puzzles
because two environmental puzzles
we're cool at first death would have
this really slick traversal while
running everything kind of stale toward
the end the game and I don't think they
kind of incorporated the puzzles
themselves into the open-world as much
as they could
Zelda games the older Zelda games it's
easier to do that because they're these
actually streamlined dungeons where you
could do that but I want to see them
integrate puzzle into the open-world
more organically that makes sense
especially I'm wondering if the her like
elemental powers will extend past combat
and into that kind of travel and whatnot
I don't know what do you guys from what
you know of dark times one two
I think you all have like brief
experience with them what are you kind
of hoping for with Darksiders three in
regards to like people from Chronos
coming back or people that you know
worked on VR games and came back you
think they could have learned anything
from Chronos your time with Chronos that
you would like to see implemented here I
mean to be honest with you the what I've
played of the first two games I didn't
have any problems with it like I kind of
would just like more of the same and I
do like how the story does jump around
between the first two so to kind of
culminate here I think that's really
cool like I I rarely say this but I just
want more the same mm-hmm I know it's
really safe answer but it's kind of true
well yeah because people a lot of people
were hoping that there would be like a
co-op game with all four horsemen but
I'm kind of glad that they're sticking
to the third-person action in terms of
bringing a new character into it and I'm
I don't know I'm curious how the whip
will work castlevania lords of Shadow
was a 3d Xbox 360 outing with a also ps3
and pc right ps3 pc that generate
he used a whip and that was actually
really satisfying combat it's kind of
like like I said Kratos the blade to
Kaos almost like that reach right
same sort of momentum yeah I don't know
from like in terms of fighting these
seven bosses and kind of Navi in this
over worlds or anything you hope to see
from it because this is your kind of
game Rob like in terms of I'm sure I
don't like gauge I mean I really not
familiar the series
you've been playing near though like
that's a third-person action right
that's what I was immediately like
trying to like make those like poles
right like oh that's that seems pretty
fun like I was walking some of the
combat looks great for two but I suppose
like the open-world you know that is
such a heavy-handed
I mean what is this a open world gonna
be like right like is it gonna be even
enjoyable compared to like I feel like
what has happened with like a horizon
and Zelda yeah because Darksiders 2 was
more of a item gated open-world kind of
like rise of the Tomb Raider
Metroidvania ish yeah would you like to
see that Callie or more of a open word
Rob or just like one you can explore
yeah like I mean I just hope there's a
reason for the open world is one kind of
say like I yeah I'd like nor more open
world games I play I have to be
entertained throughout right like like
that's why Zelda was so great they're a
dime it doesn't know right um well yeah
it's just like if they're done wrong
it's really really boring so there has
to be something some draw to it
obviously this trailer didn't really
give a whole lot of information so it
needs to know more I really like C I
really like seven deadly sins as a theme
though I was like totally my jam so it's
pretty clear structure and upfront you
know who you're gonna be fighting
exactly and it'd be really I'm assuming
they were pretty good with their bosses
and now Darksiders - especially pretty
massive scale kind of reminds me got a
war - opens up with that Colossus II
fight right away or three when you're
fighting uh but the Titans are not
Poseidon you're pretty close after
because god of war is another comparison
people make with these games kind of
because of the combat and the fact that
when you acquire a new weapon it kind of
you could switch between them on the fly
like it's blades of chaos blade of
Artemis Artemis is sword and God of War
and I'm
those in a while but in the sense that
God of War three are hunting down the
gods of Olympus taking out one by one I
that'd be pretty cool to see how the
story integrates the seven deadly sins
as bosses seems pretty like metaphysical
in terms of that's the seven bosses
you're hunting down interesting if
having to confront those sins somehow
did something to you as a character
mm-hmm
like you have to become a worse version
of yourself to actually gain power
mm-hmm or resist let me just stuff from
so strong now yeah yeah but
unfortunately not details are pretty
sparse on this game so far
IGN has the there IGN first which is
like a month long coverage of game
releases okay usually um so I know a lot
of Pierce is heading it up so she has
gameplay impressions and stuff cool but
don't go to IGN just wait until we hear
the news from them and put it on
GameSpot anyway um yeah but let us know
what you think there were questions on
Darksiders 3 on Twitter but I think we
kind of answered them I don't know
people are wondering how the progression
is going to go i fits anything like
Darksiders to you'll that was currency
based and then you come back to like one
person in the hub would be who you buy
abilities from like new like like i said
that that's where the god of war comes
in you would kind of be buying this new
sword attack this new jumping smash
attack new earthquake around you attack
so i'm really curious to see how the hub
world will function if there is one and
progressing fury skills because she
sounds super interesting she's more mage
base uh war in the first game is kind of
a brute close combat really add more
strength base like grappling and stuff
to death was really acrobatic and kind
of air juggling more that kind of style
but curiously how fury will factor in it
with a whip and elemental powers but
yeah if any questions in chat or if
you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot after let us know what you want
let us know what you think they need to
do to get you back interest is that
interest in this series after such a
long hiatus or if you're just excited
for it anyway cool all right now to
breath of the wild DLC we were grabbing
food the other day I have to work and
then
or one of you had mentioned oh [ __ ] yeah
Pete sorry I mean to give Robin credits
too much it was a conversation stopper
you're like you just knew it right
before my gosh it ideal guys but it came
at the perfect time too because I think
a lot of us finally burnt out is not the
right term but I think a lot of us were
finding like I need to put this down and
try to play a lot of other things
because this year has been off to a
fantastic start and that's an
understatement
but Zelda they have announced the first
expansion past there's another one story
base that's gonna come out sometime
holiday this year but the first
expansion the master trials was detailed
in depth here you have Southeast Asia
shots and everything so trial is sword
sounds really cool if you played
Twilight Princess it sounds similar to
the Cave of trials I might begin that
wrong but it was out in the desert but
you go through 45 rooms starting with
almost nothing almost like a pen tied
island if you played that and you looks
like you just start with a Deku stick on
your back yeah
here's hero's path mode which just
here's path mode it's going to track
you're traveling across the in-game map
so you can kind of see where you explore
yeah so you don't have to look up the
actual map online for where the shrines
are or core exceeds even yeah you get it
because I usually use shrines to kind of
dictate [ __ ] I haven't explored here
enough for I have explored here enough
how is this gonna take into account fast
travel it's gonna pretend as though you
walked there oh it's actually the maps
like 10 hours in it's just a bunch of
yeah yeah it's like uh I think 80 hours
and I realized I hadn't even been to
East neckla de yeah like it all I was
like oh [ __ ] so that would have been
really helpful because 200 hours right I
was out at sedge I think it's X 2 hours
the people that were playing in those
videos
stick to pathways much more than I do I
it looked like they weren't climbing
like I just I climb every chance I get
like I dunno I take the shortest point
from A to B possible shorts line I like
missed a place in on Death Mountain
because I just climbed up the mountain
yeah and there is a hard mode
it's kind of self-explanatory for most
parts just up bow Cobbins and mob ones
and enemies in general or increased in
rank so maybe you'll see more white bow
cabins more often no no it's that they
they take on the strength of the rank
above them so red will be as strong as
blue yes it'll be red there's not gonna
be like a new coach coming for them yeah
oh I didn't I thought it's like a whole
shift okay no it's just yeah now they're
one step up harder there also be in this
is the one locations like this I know I
know it's weird I the reason I don't
like this idea of balloons with a mob
'ln just hanging out up in the sky what
like why I don't know the whole this
this game is so immersive and I just
find like nuts but what is this what I
don't like the hideouts you come across
those good tree forts those make sense
they're outpost for them to kind of like
guard yeah well I mean this could be -
yeah yeah this guy is just keeping watch
right like he can see a lot farther he
can warn them of some welcome yeah yeah
with the hard rock limbs
yeah but those pops so quickly nothing
is high yeah I'm hung up on this - this
is like I just don't need to chew on guy
yeah it's miners help Isis something
works like I don't I just I wonder how
that's gonna play in because I just love
the game already you do you did make a
good point like it seems odd doesn't
seem as organic Yeah right yeah um if
you complete the 45 room trial of the
sword challenge the power of the Master
Sword awakens and will always be in its
glowing powered up state when I first
read that before I read it's glowing
powered up state I'm assuming that just
means it will always be at like 40
attack and it won't j6o bolt 16 does it
say that it won't break no it just says
it's always because they should they
didn't say that but so will yet it says
will always be in its glowing powered up
state right when usable is the actual
next few were right so it's twice so it
does so what is the and it needs to pray
cuz that's what just was saying like oh
well then you're not doing the actual
system of the weapons like switching out
weapons it would be boring and we maybe
it would be frustrating it like that so
that's read that I was hoping it would
be the classic Master Sword when you
have full hearts power up you shoot out
a beam you can you do that already with
a Master Sword yeah yeah in breath of
the wild yes there you go
it's the games watch and learn in every
day I play the 80 hours that game I have
the master sword why do I have two
hearts and you just do throw like try to
throw it and you'll they'll be like a
yang okay um I'm really excited for that
Korach mask yeah vibrates when you get
an attack or exceed penis 900 karate
this is way too damn many yeah so I'm
excited about some of the new armor oh
my god I didn't even notice the pinwheel
that's really cute oh okay little bun I
love like the it's the army nod this is
so minor the only thing I would say is
that like I do find the game Rick at
work can be very menu intensive and I
just feel like I mean I don't want to
look like this forever yeah but well I
now have it on always when I'm running
around I don't know exploring I think
when you cuz I have 300 core exceeds
right now and I'm at the point where I
would really like this just cuz you need
441 to max all your inventory slots
that's was sort of my goal for a while
but I hit 300 and I was super fatigued
on it yeah so what is like the max melee
weapon capacity um it's I think it's
probably the entirety of that first
payday right so many that those narrows
are different there's fewer slots for
four bows and then shields is also the
full page I don't know how many it's
like above 20 okay and you can also have
Majora's Mask which I'm pumped about I
don't so yeah no it does we don't know
and we're actually like Joey's working
on a cool video we're gonna speculate I
think we have some good ideas I'm not
this is the one actually I don't know
I'm thinking maybe something with the
Blood Moon like you get like maybe like
a powerup cuz I don't know something
time-based oh yeah that's a good call
that one's question all think the other
ones we had better ideas about they
could be like tingle
uh uh uh someone someone had the just
like you have the core rock mass to find
core exceed maybe the tingle would like
light up for fairies mm-hmm they're
nearby cuz those are always hard to find
and like on a risky friggin hot yeah
he'd I said earlier he reminds me of
like the scene in a Christmas story or
they just look so not into the fit okay
dance deadline so get going take the
picture mom I'm ready to get out of it
I'm like never ever gonna wear this I'll
wear it all the time and then the other
one or there's two other so the other
one is phantom armor god I forget what
someone said someone in the office had a
good idea what maybe this was like you
know two looks like a dark nut from
Twilight Princess the enemy I kind of
got it looks love it I kind of love this
one mm-hmm
yo first full bodysuit right you said
that looks cool I don't like [ __ ]
costume yeah I guess but even then you
can see wings face like their you can't
see anything yeah I yeah I'm excited for
this um well one more thing we want to
mention
Midna Selma too if you played toilet
princess so they're just this is
nitpicky I'm excited to have all these
things but it seems like they're just
throwing these things into here as like
Easter eggs and kind of fanservice
whatever I'm on board because I like
Majora's Mask and Twilight Princess a
lot there's a travel and alien as well
you want explain that really quick yeah
apparently well what's neat about all
the stuff which I'm excited that they're
you know you know you don't just get
everything you have to go find it you
know look for it so the medallion this
is like summer in the world and yeah
it's a one-time use for anywhere you
want fast travel which is pretty cool I
guess like if you have like if you know
of an area like I was telling you the
other day I found a tree that has every
single mushroom Oh
so if your environment yeah you're going
to collect cool cooking recipes you can
sell your medallion there and always go
back to it posted getting into a shrine
and then having chopped that's so cool
for if you farm something right yeah
sweet yeah dragons
uh I'm also interested in how you find
these because for the kuraki mass
specific lee they said it's just in a
chest somewhere in the world so I wonder
you're going to be coming across people
who have dialogue to kind of mention
this or if it's going to be you're going
to get the masks from what's-his-name I
mean that kind of leads into my question
which is like is all this stuff gonna be
a better experience with a fresh
playthrough yeah like how how is that
going to fit into that again mmm I guess
I'm inclined I can't I haven't even I'm
at 130 hours I haven't beaten the game
yet
I can't just do it I can't you have to
just do it I was waiting I have two more
shrines I'm gonna do and I've been
playing other games like you want to hit
Ganon uh sooner than later
it's way too easy like when I did it I
was like oh this is I was stalling
because I wanted to experience it but I
just completely like what you do the
four dungeons and then look hearts like
I sort of like you have all the masks in
Majora's Mask and you fight and it's
like oh that was faster than I thought
makes the journey more fun though
getting all those well yeah the same
thing with breath a wild I think that
it's not even about Ganon that's how I
feel like I'm I want to get all the
shrines and then go and I have two more
so yeah alright well that is the master
trials expansion for zelda they're gonna
announce more about the story based
expansion later on in the year they said
that will release holiday 2017 let us
know if this is going to bring you back
into breath of the wild if you've left
it are you going to start a new game are
you just going to start looking for
these things right from your current
savefile let us know also show us the
best pictures you can draw with that
heroes path mode I don't care how vulgar
it is just send it my way it uh cool
well that was our show that was a weird
show that was a weird show yeah yeah
yeah maybe we should have done that as a
produced segment know that wasn't
meddling oh no nope I like this s it you
heard more first it was a success so if
g'day g'day g'day oh ho Jima had
directed Sandlot I think I would like to
even more one of my favorite movies but
you know fresh take heroes get remember
what's going on today yes
so at 1 p.m. Pacific in an hour we are
gonna be playing some new segments of
prey with some people from Arkane
studios they're going to come in and
show us a set Shane's gonna be here as a
lead a systems designer and we're gonna
have a level designer in here and I'm
going to be hosting that and I'm pretty
pumped to see some new stuff today so
come back to twitch YouTube or GameSpot
add 1 p.m. to watch that and I'm sure
we'll get some cool stuff and if you
haven't yet try out the break demo that
releases Friday see we think let us know
yeah as always thanks for joining us in
YouTube twitch gamespot chats richard
lee eric page
Saiki and joey thank you for your help
today
we'll be back next week same time see
you then